[Musica]
lo vedete questo è uno smartphone uno
dei tanti smartphone che abbiamo
circolazioni questi giorni l'oggetto del
desiderio di grandi e piccini
bene se avete uno smartphone ma anche se
per esempio avete un computer
se avete una carta di credito bancomat
sono entrato usate sistema sanitario
locale
vuol dire che fate parte integrante
della società dei dati ma per esempio
anche il fatto stesso che la vostra foto
anche vostra insaputa sia stata un
giorno pubblicata su facebook per
esempio o su instagram o su twitter da
uno dei vostri conoscenti significa che
il vostro bel faccione e le vostre
informazioni personali sono già parte di
qualche banca dati che va anche nati da
questo per la maggior parte dei casi non
ci è dato saperlo
quello che sappiamo però è di chi vi
posso assolutamente assicurare è che
siamo in buona compagnia in quella che
molto ho appena chiamato la società dei
dati
cos'è questa società dei dati forse è
una parola una combinazione di parole
che non si sente a usare spesso eppure
come li aveva dimostrato ci siamo
immersi tutti fino al collo si tratta di
un sistema di produzione di valore
economico principalmente che si basa
sulla produzione massiccia e diciamo
proprio a tappeto di dati dati che sono
disponibili in formato digitale
ma da dove saltano fuori questi dati
come vi dicevo per esempio facendo una
ricerca su rimedi per il corona biros on
line noi stessi però diciamo dei dati
usando il cellulare andando in banca
usando per esempio l'app immuni se ce
l'avete installata ma ci sono anche
tantissimi altri attori non solo
individui semplici cittadini come
io ho già parlato delle imprese private
che usano i dati in maniera molto
efficiente per migliorare il proprio
business ma anche abbiamo per esempio lo
stato che usa dati a volte prende anche
disponibili per la cittadinanza per nel
tentativo se non altro di migliorare i
propri servizi ai cittadini
l'idea che più si sa del mondo nel
contesto in cui cittadini si muovono più
si riesce a intercettare quel che
possono essere i loro bisogni e perché
no magari anche a prevederle pensate per
esempio agli algoritmi che incontri
accodi al software che incontriamo in
una piattaforma di ecommerce come amazon
che prevede spesso quelli che sono i
nostri gusti in fatto di retro domestici
o di libri e attrezzatura sportiva
io presente solo ciclista e usa un'app
molto carina per contare dal primo
gennaio quanti chilometri pena lo sa e
non hanno ma chi per esempio al diabete
può usare anche molti strumentini
innovativi che sono usciti recentemente
per per esempio controllare il polimero
di due cose alessandro quindi la società
di dati portano a serie di benefici non
solo per i grandi del web
pensate presenti ad amazon a google a
facebook per nominare diaby diciamo ma
anche ovviamente a noi cittadini diciamo
ordinari quindi si tratta di una
questione economica
la società di dati in un certo senso è
come è la modalità con cui queste grandi
compagnie che vi ho appena menzionato
fare i soldi ma è anche una questione
sociale è anche una questione
addirittura socio culturale nel senso
che la possibilità di generare ed
imparare dai dati cambia e ha cambiato
radicalmente il nostro modo di essere
mondo e di percepire il mondo che ci
circonda
stesso modo in cui per esempio negli
anni 30 i primi spettatori che in
programma televisivo bianco e nero
improvviso analizzarlo potete vedere
questi toni di dei costi molto lontani
camere altrimenti come si tratta di
questo cambio e vocale ma se si tratta
di un fenomeno globale come sta messo il
nostro paese ovviamente se pensiamo alle
alle grandi industrie del tech che vi ha
nominato in precedenza pensiamo alla
sirico palle siano agli stati uniti
d'america la california ma in italia
sotto certi aspetti non siamo da meno
portiamo qualche dato allora ci
riferiamo ai comuni cittadini
e se guardiamo un report del 2019 di
l'ultimo disponibile del
l'organizzazione per la cooperazione e
lo sviluppo economico che racchiude 36
paesi dell'unione europea e anche della
della zona limitrofa diciamo scopriamo
che per quanto riguarda l'accesso a
internet a cui la possibilità di usare
questi strumenti
siamo ben piazzati ben 82 per cento dei
cittadini e delle cittadine italiane ha
infatti accesso all'internet la cosa in
radicalmente cambiata vi posso
assicurare con l'introduzione dei
telefoni smart prima come sapete alla
fibra per esempio non arriva in tutti i
lati in italia tra l'altro neanche in
tutti gli angoli del veneto è per
esempio pure a una delle regioni più
kiwi che in italia quindi questa la
buona notizia
siamo ben messi rispetto anche agli
altri paesi
se però guardiamo a un aspetto cruciale
per sopravviva dei dati che è quello del
sapersi muovere in questo ambiente
complesso fatto di tecnologie di banche
dati di device infrastrutture a 1 la
nuvola spesso invisibili abbastanza
difficile un po da catturare anche da
poco da immaginare abbiamo bisogno di
competenze allo stesso modo per cui
quando io vado in strada e devo guidare
devo sapere che lo stop segni di stop
col dire ferma un attimo guarda a destra
ea sinistra
quindi abbiamo bisogno di competenza
bene nel momento in cui guardiamo le
competenze digitali dell'italiano medio
scopriamo che si hanno in realtà messa
molto male cioè sempre secondo lo stesso
rapporto che visitano prima solo il 36
per cento dei cittadini italiani ha le
necessarie competenze per sopravvivere
in questo ambiente tecnologico molto
complesso e ancor di più per
sopravvivere nel mondo del lavoro che
diventa sempre più digitale pensate a
tutta l'enfasi di questi ultimi mesi
per quanto riguarda il rispetto dello
smart work non ci mancano solo gli
strumenti
diciamo che gli strumenti fisici il
computer il telefono magari ci abbiano
non abbiamo quattro per famiglie magari
abbiamo uno solo quello che ci manca è
sapersi muovere in una mina in maniera
che protegga la nostra privacy protegga
i nostri dati personali non ci esponga a
pericoli ma che ci aiuti a capire ea
filtrare le informazioni che ci arrivano
dal web
allora immaginate quanto ci teniamo
ognuno di noi a mangiare bene non solo
perché siamo italiani ma perché nel 2020
è importante essere in buona salute
curiosamente però non prestiamo la
stessa attenzione che prestiamo al cibo
e al frigorifero hardware c'è la nostra
dieta e l'informativa è come se non ci
fossero ci pensiamo proprio a parte
anche normale tra provoca dei problemi
veramente ingenti
ve la racconto un paio allora la
pandemia in particolare sta facendo
emergere dei fenomeni negativi diciamo
della società dei dati che ci sembrano
degli scenari quasi apocalittici quasi
estremi ma ci sono reali qui ed ora bene
dicono per esempio i disturbi
dell'informazione del della pandemia
cioè il fatto che siamo bombardati da
informazioni dalle fonti più svariate
facciamo veramente fatica a discriminare
tra quello che è corretto quello che
invece magari invece teoria cospirativa
felicemente una cattiva informazione
senza le scientifica per esempio uno
studio recente dell'università di oxford
ha anche scoperto che queste cattive
notizie diciamo le notizie tossiche per
il nostro organismo
la nostra testa soprattutto arrivi sono
prodotte sia le persone malintenzionate
ma anche da persone che male nazionale
non sono come magari esperti che
condividono dati scientifici che non
sono ancora stati corroborati dalle
ricerche per esempio
allora solo il 38 per cento fra l'altro
della cattiva informazione della miss
information che viene è stata
rintracciata sul web dell'università di
oxford nel periodo iniziale del dow è
stato creato di proposito il resto
semplicemente informazione magari
condivisa in buona fede magari anche da
noi ma che di fatto finisce per
risultare tossica per l'organismo sia
individuale sia sociale
pensate per esempio al falso mito degli
africani muoia virus che ha creato
purtroppo un'ondata di estrazione
razzista sul web
l'altro fenomeno di cui vi voglio
parlare sempre molto tossico per il
nostro organismo è quello che possiamo
chiamare il tvc l'anti smo digitale
cos'è il pg razzismo digitale
allora è la tentazione che fabiano
vorrei che noi professiamo un po
annoiate a caso durante lordan di
ergerci di assumere diciamo delle
competenze che non sono nostre
cioè di controllo del comportamento
altrui non solo quindi magari ci
arricchiamo vi sicuramente vi ricordate
alcuni casi perché la gente sta
camminando fuori quando fuori non ci
deve stare ma facciamo una fotina e la
pubblichiamo magari sono le nostre reti
sociali è un atteggiamento tossico
perché perché solo per dirne a
raccontarvi alcune delle conseguenze
lesive della privacy altrui non sappiamo
esattamente perché quella persona sia
per esempio fuori ma che crea esclusione
sistema sociale e ingenti danni
psicologici
allora mi raccontavi solo due
potrei raccontare molti altri di questi
nemici che sono in un certo senso quasi
invisibili nel momento in cui tutta la
nostra società si sta occupando sta
dedicando tante energie a risolvere
quello che principalmente di salute
drammatico come il comit eppure ciò non
toglie che l'ambiente informatico è data
a ficato dove noi ci muoviamo è
importante e dobbiamo assolutamente
guardarci da questi pericoli e imparare
quindi per concludere
dobbiamo pensare di restare fuori forse
è meglio nascondersi non dalla società
dei dati visto che questa società dei
dati di fatto nasconde così tante
insidie
ecco io da best ha posso dire
assolutamente di non farlo società
didattici dante le opportunità veramente
nuove per cambiare il nostro modo di
vedere il mondo per cambiare i nostri
modelli prendersi cura anche presente
del nostro corpo
quindi vediamo quali potrebbero essere
tre piccole semplici regole per una
buona dieta informativa per sopravvivere
e trarne vantaggio dalla società dei
dati numero uno allora bisogna diventare
più consapevoli seri rischi che delle
possibilità
informiamoci ci sono moltissime risorse
che ci permettono di capire meglio
quelli che sono gli aspetti del web che
magari ci possono sembrare invisibili o
impossibili da comprendere o addirittura
un po magici
penso per esempio agli algoritmi seconda
regola se questo vale per gli adulti
vale ancora di più per i ragazzi e per i
nostri bambini
queste nuove generazioni partono a usare
il web
da quando sono forse ancora in fasce
dobbiamo aiutarli anche attraverso
l'educazione a scuola a usare queste
tecnologie in una maniera che il portégé
per esempio da rischi come il bullismo
online ma che allo stesso tempo li
prepari a le sfide di domani è il terzo
vi prego prendete di cura della vostra
privacy
decidete con un po di sale in zucca cosa
mettere per esempio sul web e cosa
invece per esempio tenere per un
contesto ha più familiare quindi magari
fuori dall ambito digitale e per
concludere come prestiamo attenzione a
quello che mangiamo
prestiamo attenzione anche a quello che
[Musica]